hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play only a Oni now
I not sure what the hell just happened
there but welcome to let's play our Oni
now I've wanted to play before I got to
this one but I couldn't get to work and
I didn't have enough time to figure it
out because I am being shipped out to LA
and then in Seattle for PAX Prime so I
am going to be all over the place real
quick but I'm recording this beforehand
so that you guys have that delicious
content I'm gonna be trying to record
while I'm out there but if I cannot then
you still got this so let's go what is
the main character's name only the
coolest name of them all and it's not
that by the way how do I backspace how
do I go backwards no no oh really oh
really you're not gonna let me oh really
oh really really he's gonna need me
named her ocean that's his name fine you
know whatever that's his name I guess
her ocean everybody say hello to her
ocean we heard a rumor about a mansion
on the outskirts of town they say there
is a monster that lives there I'm
assuming that they are right it's a lot
prettier on the inside is it just me or
is it cold in here hey well let's get
out of here
What's Wrong Takeshi you scared crashed
I could make some marks hey let's get
out of here wait didn't you just say
that so stupid there's no way monsters
can exist is scientifically impossible
hey her ocean be careful oh no I'm going
it so that was a quick introduction the
door is locked so let's get to it
hmm something strange happened here
there was a broken plate a place
shattered on the ground
I found the item plate shard I'm gonna
use that to stab somebody in the face
preferably okay so now with these RPG
horror maker games or PC era maker or
whatever there's a lot of stuff that
needs to be explored so I need to get
every nook and cranny Oh Oh my friends
are gone hey where'd you go guys guys
it's your old buddy her ocean hello hi
is there something in there I'm coming
in oh we won't open
okay I'm going away I'm not going that
way I'm going back the way I came in an
orderly fashion so ignore me I'm stupid
what's with all the dorks it won't open
let me get the front door won't open
either yep
okay everything won't open so I guess
I'm going upstairs can I like run no
that's my only speed Wow nice five-year
old cartoon drawing on here
I completed budget with just after okay
whatever it won't open
Wow go away okay C closet drawers
drawers drawers the book I know you cut
it out there you cut it out now hello
who's in there what oh hi Oh to kiss him
there Takeshi how's it going there buddy
Takashi Takashi shivering where are the
other stock she taught Takeshi shivering
still Hilary can't you talk are you
gonna say the same thing that you said
before hey hey what's going on alright
fine be that way I'll go find the others
you just stay quivering in that closet
Takashi come out of the closet
Takashi okay won't open okay so every
single door is locked in this entire
house besides that one door let's go
what is going on are they like wait hang
on let me look at this map again okay so
that's the bottom floor there's actually
it says there's more rooms it says like
there's a double stack of rooms over to
the right of this hallway but it doesn't
look like it wait a minute that can't be
you're all in the back Oh in the back of
the bottom floor that's the that's the
floor for the first map but I can't get
that open well well well
seems like we have a predicament here
what is going on okay so I got the glass
shard what do I do with it
how do I get to my there we go menu I'm
gonna save all I can before something
happens I've got a plate shard but what
do I do with okay obviously I can't pick
a lock with a play chart I don't know
what the hell is going through my mind
woahh look through here take a seat tell
me something what's going on here stop
shivering like a little bubble blowing
baby grow some balls and let's go Oh No
who's your monster who's your ax
maybe I'll just take a nap can I take a
nap no it's my mom it's my mom texting
me
shoutout mom I'm recording a very
important video mother whom I love very
much mom okay anyway let's go through
here
ah yeah the only way I haven't gone now
is to the left here there was something
there hang on let me use a plate share
density maybe I gotta stab my friend
with the plate shard to give him some
courage as he goes along his way maybe
that's gotta be it
you know what's funny you guys are all
gonna laugh at it my mom is actually a
nurse so if I I when I yelled shut up to
my mom I was you literally yelling shut
up nurse so you guys probably found that
so hilarious and y'all laughing right
now and rolling all over the floor
ha ha ha ha okay shut up I am totally
lost I have no idea what I'm supposed to
do I am at a complete loss I've been
everywhere the door won't open I what am
i doing
what am I doing with my life what am I
doing with my life here what am i doing
with my life map tell me your secrets
there's got to be some way to get back
here behind this one nope nope no it's
all lie it's all a lie dr. sham is a
liar hawkish Hiroshi I'm sorry Takeshi
and her ocean Oh Kimmy Kimmy GABA - give
me give me GABA
give it a gala give it give it give it
give it give me the GABA - give it a go
is there something in that little drawer
over way over here there better not be
okay there wasn't I was actually kind of
hoping there would be so that I could
get out of here sooner earlier then I
had before hello Kashi those problems we
got problems hey hey snap out of it
there's a monster oh come on
how was able to do that you son of a
[ __ ] okay I found the library key now
where's the library
do I have to actually use the library
key on the first floor okay it's on the
floor floor maybe that's where that
shadow went by okay I got this I got
this
sorry sorry I'm an idiot lady maybe is
here no no okay where's the library
where's the library was the library
where's the library
okay they'll use the library key okay hi
[Music]
that the monster oh god I look at the
book I found an item the bedroom key so
I gotta move I literally that ah god
night
yes out of us your big in blue purple
purple blue purple blue where do I hide
Takeshi can you help me I think if I to
save me screw you you son of a [ __ ]
ah game over poop poop poop poop II poop
but but poopy butt okay
Takeshi you son of a [ __ ] if you
dropped a rock that stopped me from
getting where I needed to go well you
crapped your pants right there on the
floor and I tripped over it and it was
just awful
okay so this time I'm not gonna like you
in this game am i you're a son of a
[ __ ] okay no let's go let's go don't
need to look let's just go this is giant
purple monster coming out yeah coming at
ya hot and heavy you didn't see [ __ ]
Dada okay so nothing happened am i okay
there we go yeah all right suck that
down big purple monster
I found the item hand the kerchief
hankerchief so tickety was crying like a
bubble blowing baby and couldn't keep it
all together in okay bedroom on the
third floor sweet I should read the
description of the things I need to
become more involved in what I'm doing
use the bedroom key is that another
hiding space I heard something you can't
tell me I didn't hear something I heard
something you liars liar
what am I supposed to do it I fell in a
hole what the hell okay so this game
involves a lot of pushing things around
there's a piano not being suddenly
getting a flood of memories from back in
Mario 64 in the piano suddenly went
kachunk kachunk kachunk you know the
most oh look another thing that I got to
move wait wait okay I got a good
combination I don't trust that piano
piano piano piano buddy okay there's
blood blood all the keys that's good
that's great that's it unlock the door
to here okay wait there must be
something there oh I got a hankerchief
can I wipe it off cuz there under
something under the line hey come on I
thought that I thought for sure all
right so that's not a thing maybe if I
use the play chart on it
no wait maybe here I use wipe it off
with a swirling motion with your left
and right arrows wipe the blood off the
keys nope okay so that's not a thing I
need to maybe I need to wet the rag in
the kitchen oh I'm so smart I'm so smart
and handsome that butt stabber ain't got
nothing on me hey man let me try this
what the anchor table come on
I am on a roll I am so smart right now
you can't even stop how smart I am maybe
I could soak it in takeshi's tears and
then wipe the blood off maybe there was
something in the library that I missed
because it was a giant monster chasing
me
hello I love LA yeah
nope nope nope nope okay
okay there's nothing here or at least I
don't think there's anything here so
what we have here is a failure to
communicate there must be something we
wasn't Oh didn't that map say that there
were drums back this away oh yeah oh no
no no get away get away get away I gotta
go back to my hidey hole go to go back
to my guy around the cops yeah suck on
that screw you buddy screwin you and you
you smelt handsome face there have you
been doing those facial exercises cuz
your head seems kind of 10 times bigger
than your body anyway what would I what
did I go in there for I have no idea is
that hello
found the item lighter what do I need a
lighter for can I hide in there that
would be nice
that would be lovely there's more stuff
over here
wait I see something there's something
there something seems off about this
wallpaper well rip it down cut it with
the plate chard yeah I can't even do
what do you mean it's a hole in the wall
it's not a door
you're you're a door use a lighter it
won't light well whatever then fine fine
fine then the door's locked that door
was open you son of a [ __ ] I got to go
dropping down through the bedroom really
I got to go all the way wait hey let me
it's gonna it's gonna yeah okay I have
no idea what
wait did I have another no I have a
lighter that needs fluid a plate chard
and a hand kerchief which I could have
sworn was gonna be used to wipe off the
blood for that way let me see over here
ah this magically opened now for some
reason that looks like another Heidi
closet someone in there Takeshi I don't
need to be in here why am I in there why
am i acting like a total [ __ ] okay
that's weird all right so there's a
weird door here can I somehow take this
off the wall like rip it off and then
put it on the door down below or at
least you know take those picta take the
handle at least at the very least okay
so that was weird
this game kind of strained whoa boom
thump sorry just only shattered my knees
I'm okay though
don't mind me hankerchief lighter it
won't light your face won't light up a
room with your smile okay so what do I
do
I'll just keep doing this till I
randomly good well screw you and your
face in it must be tied to the the piano
in some way because those shapes those
shapes look like the piano keys but I'm
thinking that there are numbers under
that blood there's got to be numbers
under that blood right or something you
gotta be wipe it off okay so I'm gonna
check some of the other rooms in the
house now cuz I've been kind of just
wandering around since that door opened
upstairs I'm guessing that some other
doors may have opened up just a guess it
like this one gonna save before I go in
actually I'm all out of time so we're
gonna get to that later so I'm gonna
leave it on cliffhanger every time so a
you are like oh man what's gonna happen
neck oh I wanna see it so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation more tears I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]
haha